let me bring in Sean Salisbury during
his long NFL career our following guest
was so good he got to play for the
Seahawks and the Colts and the Vikings
and the Chargers in the Oilers and I
could keep going on and on but I don't
have that much time they also want a
championship and no not this Super Bowl
a Grey Cup close enough it's my honor to
introduce a man who can't even walk down
the streets of Winnipeg this day without
being mobbed our good friend Sean
Salisbury Sean brought one good knee
with him he's playing hurt and a little
replacement surgery there yeah total
knee replacement good to be on with you
guys how did you get hurt is a bear the
i-team has a report on Sean Salisbury's
knee injuries and our sources say that
Sean Salisbury injured his knee playing
ping-pong that's the word on the street
you know when I was in that line Austin
with my son dodge and this is about I've
been about 11 weeks in with this surgery
and about six weeks in I'm in Austin and
there's this really great restaurant bar
brand new that has like 10,000 ping-pong
balls you grab a ping-pong table and
play and so we're playing and in the
middle of it he hits one of those little
drop shots to the side that you got to
go forehand then he hits another one i
backhand I get to him both he catches
the ball on the way back and I hit it
back and he stops it he goes man pops I
haven't seen you do that in about 25
years so the reaction time is back well
Wow their action time is back are you
better right now than Phillip Rivers is
right now is you're stronger than
Phillip Rivers right now maybe okay but
I move about like Phillip does no matter
you know what going to the Colts though
you guys mentioned yeah the reason why
that's perfect for him is they got a
good roster an offensive line he doesn't
have to move out of the hula hoop so it
makes sense veteran coach understands
veteran players in Frank Reich I
actually think it makes perfect sense
for the Colts on a roster that can
protect him he can't move though all
right but what do you do with the
Chargers if you got the number six pick
and you know are you putting Tyrod
Taylor in there and
and maybe you drafted one of these
younger players he's one of the perfect
backups and he's been like that Steve de
Berg bridge guy it seems like every year
they go get somebody else right wherever
he is I'll tell you what let's just say
the Patriots prot argue that the
Chargers pride Tom Brady from the
Patriots he decides I'm gonna go sign a
two-year deal with the Chargers roster
Keenan Allen hunter Henry good line
strong defense pass rushers chance to
win get to play against them homes of
the world and then you can still draft
the quarterback why not why not why not
have the the Herbert or to whoever's
there and then start Tom Brady you know
what you get you know like the like
Philip Rivers where he's gonna be but
you also know his arms still he still
got 90 in his fastball and you'd give
him players and a better offense if
you're really looking into it and we're
gonna start you know creating conspiracy
theories isn't that the best place for
Brady if he leaves the Patriots if he
has the you know the wherewithal to
leave or if they let him get out of the
building yeah I'm just wondering if
Brady truly wants to go back to the
Patriots Robert Kraft says the Patriots
want him back right then why won't this
happen man McDaniels is still there yeah
makes sense oh no III personally I don't
think he's leaving but there's that
temptation when you look at the
offensive roster for the Patriots and
Tom early in his career and in the
middle of his career well quite frankly
up until he's about 40 or 41 could take
guys that were average a five and make
him a seven Dan and I think we saw for
the first time and I think Brady's the
go-to I don't even think it's questioned
and I still think he can play I still
think he can win a championship I think
he's that smart and that good but it's
to the point now it's like when you're
being raised by your family and then it
gets the point when they're like 80 and
you got to take care of your parents
that switches Tom's been taking care of
a roster of there's been great players
but there's been some where he said it
turned a guy we've never heard of who
played lacrosse into a really good
player now it's time that they give him
a bunch of players and imagine right now
if you're Brady Brady's not playing to
finish third in the division why would
he he's playing to win and so with that
roster if they can promise them they're
gonna go out and get three receivers and
compete that's one thing but their
offense was putrid this year and I can
understand the temptation for Brady to
want to stay and play his whole career
there but
also the temptation to say let me make
one more run at it if the Patriots
aren't going to fill a roster
offensively they've got to find players
that can help him it's that stage right
now I think we put too much blame on
Brady this year not enough on Belichick
as much as we want to give credit when
they win when it comes to blame it feels
like the blame goes towards Brady more
than it does Belichick did he draft the
right guys did they did they prepare for
Gronk not playing you know it was a
makeshift offensive line I thought they
should have gone after Emmanuel Sanders
great I thought that that at the time I
said the Patriots need him more than
anybody does but I don't know if that
would have been enough for this team but
I don't know Belichick did a great job
with that offensive roster was it his
best job and here's what's funny guys
we're saying this they're 12 and 4 right
yeah they were able with defense and you
know piece and things together and I bet
you if you talk to Belichick bill would
tell you in private that he didn't do
his best job but he's gonna move on to
it and think in 2020 and here's what's
interesting about that Dan I think that
you get so spoiled with success and you
say oh that guy's been so great we've
been able games that we saw this year
that we're within a touchdown and you
say it's no problem it's the final Drive
Tom's gonna he's gonna it's like Mikey
and the life cereal commercial right
he's gonna bail us out let's get him to
do it they couldn't do it the guy
couldn't separate Tom maybe didn't hit
the window that he wanted to this year
and Tom will probably tell you didn't
have a message to the dog yes at home
exactly and they lost back to what
back-to-back games at a time and we
never see that so yeah I think it got to
the point and when you get too late into
the season Dan as you know this there's
nothing you can do but they did they
missed out on personnel and I think they
said Brady you're so good and have been
so great for so long that you'll bail us
out and it didn't happen this year and
even though 12 and 4 was an ugly
offensive 12 and 4 if they don't make
offensive changes the rest of the
league's catching them and you see how
good these Chiefs are offensively in the
AFC Josh Allen's bills are getting
better they need to put players around
Tom and I still think if you got the
right mix Tom Brady's still good enough
to win go ahead and tell him he's not in
he'll battle you till the end
Shawn Salisbury joining us he of course
is the host of Sports Talk 790 in
Houston former NFL quarterback you it's
this question with the Super Bowl has
always come down to this
you know mahomes is considered to be a
whole lot better than Jimmy Garoppolo I
think the Niners are a better team than
Kansas City great I just
the Niners don't have a Tyreke Hill they
have a Kittel to match Kelsey their
offensive line their running game their
defense is better than Kansas City this
comes down to
Patrick mahomes is the reason why the
Chiefs are favored in this Super Bowl
can Jimmy Garoppolo come from ten points
down in the fourth quarter to win this
game on Sunday if if he needs to they
may not even need it yeah I think you
hit my limit with the 10 points if this
is one where the track meet becomes it's
20 1 2 3 it's different damn don't you
feel like when you're watching the the
49ers now that you're going to and a
half decades back tight ends Kittel run
the for the receiver on a on a motion
fake jet sweep and then fake bootleg old
Tom Rathman get him to the flat I mean I
feel like I'm watching Kyle's dad coach
and even even before they're so old
school and so physical down 10 points in
the middle of the third quarter yeah
look at Garoppolo numbers within seven
points and look at Garoppolo what a top
five and completion percentage and
touchdowns he's really good the problem
is when I say this to you Dan who's the
greatest receiver of all time answer
quickly Jerry and you don't even think
about it right are we to the point now
when we say who's the best quarterback
in the NFL who you saying I don't go
homes as quickly as I would Jerry Rice
not as quickly but are you I go home I
mean Jerry Rice is clear Randy Moss
probably second but when it comes to now
the ability to do things under pressure
to bring you from behind to play out in
front with a great play caller and Andy
Reid all those things up to the point
now there's not a general manager or a
coach and I don't care what they say in
public if I took him into a conference
room and we were sitting having a cup of
coffee or a cold beer 64 of them I say
you got the first pick of any current
player in the league you know they're
taking mahomes and they're not gonna
hesitate yeah so with this now they're
down 21 to 3 we've seen it mahomes you
want to die a fast death or a slow death
mahomes I'll heal you hit you for four
touchdowns in one quarter and you're
like what would happen this 49ers they
punch you in the gut and around round
eight you're starting to hyperventilate
a little bit and then you go to your
corner you guys says you do it okay yeah
I've got okay and you're seeing a tattoo
different
two different ways and then they hit you
with another gut punch and Kittel
where's a guy out the secondary and then
the receivers get downfield they're
blocking for a most dirt 40 yard run and
before you know it you're in the middle
the fourth quarter and you're saying
it's still only 23 to 13 but I feel like
Muhammad Ali and ramai can beat me down
yeah in a long fight so I do think
Garoppolo I think we under 8 Garoppolo
because the overall team maybe the best
in the league as far as complete but
mahomes imagine if you flipped and said
mahomes is a quarterback for the 49ers
it'd be an 8 9 10 point spread so that's
the difference would you check with your
guy in Vegas
if mahomes was on the 49ers if you swap
teams yeah swap quarterbacks they're
just the quarterback I'll check but
usually in a high-end game like this it
wouldn't change that much but during the
regular season if let's say Mahadev
mahomes was on San Francisco that
wouldn't change this that would have to
be the flavors yes yes it would be a
couple points but during the regular
season let's say mahomes suddenly was
out for a Monday night game that would
be six or seven points and that would be
probably the most in the league
six or seven points that that would
change if mahomes was scratched for a
game and a line changed I want to ask
you this before I let you go and that
has to do with Eli Manning we're gonna
wait five years and I asked Peter King
does it help or hurt Eli Manning that
there is a five year window before we
vote on him for the Pro Football Hall of
Fame what do you say I'm gonna wait for
your answer first I copy off his paper
here I personally don't cheat off
anybody's paper if I would've had a
better starting quarterback I would say
what to us
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we lost a Bowling Green in the
recruiting classes slow down where
didn't crushed everywhere I you know Dan
I think it hurt him I think it would
hurt him
I think eli manning's the Hall of Famer
and hears it now listen I grew
everything I did growing up except the
performance was Joe Namath I wore those
old Rydell cleats know that Joe wore the
number number 12 the three bar faced
massive marina war and then the Joe
Namath war the way wrist bands I pushed
on my shoulder pad you know the way Joe
I did that I mean everything I did was
Namath him I didn't wear a mink coat but
everything I did and so I looked and
then I go back and I had name if I hold
him to such high regard but when you
look at his numbers and I know that what
Joe did the impact because of the Super
Bowl and the guarantee well I don't
think Joe's a hall-of-famer but he's in
my point it's different it's it's it is
different and I get it but when you
think and I know people say well the
winds and Lawson's but this ain't tennis
and golf this is football and I know why
you know what's funny we judge pitchers
and quarterbacks why don't we say well
how many games did the wide receivers in
the Hall of Fame win he's part of it or
the right tackle it's always the
quarterback I think he is and I think
the Manning name doesn't hurt John John
Dan if he's sitting on the fence and
somebody says well he's a good guy he's
won two Super Bowls he played his best
in the biggest games of his career and
he played in New York which is a
difficult play and did what he did
it took him on the road after they
started on to that year they beat an 18
and OH Patriots team I do and I think
we've got to look at the quarterback
position more than just raw numbers it's
amazing a guy throws four numbers and
doesn't want a Super Bowl he sucks we
can't have him then the guy puts up
Super Bowls but doesn't have the numbers
of say a Dan Marino and cycle out we
can't put him in Eli put up numbers
durability one of the most underrated
parts is game durable yeah and he won
two Super Bowls I think it would hurt
him more because the longer we wait and
we see the gaudy numbers that guys are
putting up people all of a sudden same
allele I didn't have those gotti numbers
through too many pics and if you're
gonna judge a career on interceptions
then you better judge Babe Ruth or
Reggie Jackson or Aaron judge by their
strikeouts we should I mean he overcame
it's got to suit floorings he's in the
Hall of Fame and he'll be won't be a
first-ballot but he'll make it in the
third or fourth
around can you put on the headphones do
you have head trauma tomorrow we got a
surprise for a seat he'll help you you
know we got a surprise for you before
you go Paulie yeah as we all know Shawn
was one of the co-hosts of this show
back in the day we had a lot of fun
Shawn back in the day and this is one of
your personal favorite interviews Shawn
I think this is 2005 with former Yankee
great Mickey rivers don't do this to me
see the people he's gonna be a land so
you know you don't let me get saw I saw
something move one move but my favorite
is when he laughs at the end like he
just delivered a great punch line I
don't know what he said looked at me
like dude can you what do you say yeah I
said I don't know and then I look at you
because you want the interview over I
know and then you followed up by going
gee how many Reggie Jackson stories
have Reggie Jackson stories I won't be
able to understand this I turned my mic
off and I'm friggin crying dad looks at
me when I say Reggie Jackson stories
Mickey but here's the kicker greatest
kicker ever this is when you talk to him
about Bucky dude's bat and he was
interviewing Bucky as if Bucky was on
the air but Bucky wasn't there and I'm
listening to this
oh my god
and then he started with you know nachos
and I don't know what he said tonight
I'm just like let's wrap it up hey I can
picture what Mickey was talking about
how you doing it was all quick in the
batter's box you know how he'd always
shrug his shoulders in the batter's box
that was I've had somebody pressure to
me he's got a rest or he almost got
arrested at the toll booth memory the
toll booth guy then he was on the phone
with mr. Steinbrenner you cannot nobody
wasn't unfocused ever apparently was on
the phone with Bucky
great see you buddy controllable thanks
guys for more Dan Patrick show tune in
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]